a special day for 78 year old raymond
who's finally got his first dose of the
coronavirus vaccine
at the second time of asking do you
feel excited um relieved don't think of
words
this is living proof of the vaccine
program expanding in the uk
we've got a brand new center we've got
new age groups coming online
we've got new people coming into
vaccines all the time
the only question is do we have enough
vaccine
yet if supply is tight in the uk it's
even tighter in europe
where no country comes close to the uk
in terms of doses administered per 100
people
the eu is accusing the pharmaceutical
companies
of cutting short their promise supply
europe invested billions to help develop
the world's
first covet 19 vaccines
to create a truly global common good
and now the companies must deliver
they must honor their obligations
the eu has threatened to impose export
controls on vaccinations made in the
block
which could in theory threaten the uk's
vaccine supply
the vaccine minister called for calm
no one is saying until the whole world
is safe from this which is why we need
to work together
rather than as the head of w.h oversaid
rather than vaccine nationalism
the root of the rao is said to be the
supply of vaccines from astrazeneca
it said any shortfalls were simply a
result
of overall falls in yield the head of
the nhs
said everyone was facing the same
problem
the uk just started earlier yes
there is a supply shortage uh if there
were unlimited vaccines
then you wouldn't see what uh the
european uh commission was saying
yesterday you wouldn't see
italy attempting to sue one of the
manufacturers you wouldn't see
germany in uproar as it is uh today so
of course there's a supply shortage and
uh we've done very well in this country
to get the supply we have available
to us that's reassuring for the new
vaccine centers
but although staff said supply was good
there's no denying there could be more
of it
here and around the world roland menthol
sky news